- Little Jugnoo, "Is it true
that keeping urine and bladder
for a longer time than
usual risks kidney health?"
Oh, this is really good.
I haven't done a responding
to comments video
in quite a long time.
With COVID-19 and my recent addiction
to these gaming videos, I think it's time.
Ethan Green, "I haven't
had, remembered a dream
for more than eight years now.
Absolutely no recall
or memory of any dream.
Is this a problem or doesn't matter?"
Doesn't matter, not everyone
remembers their dreams.
In fact, some people that
even remember their dreams,
it doesn't happen to them every night.
It's like a natural
variance amongst humans.
Zachary Kornfeld questioned,
"Does seltzer water
and normal water give
you the same hydration?"
Yes, I think they give you
the same amount of hydration.
I do think that seltzer water's not great
for those who are suffering with reflux,
meaning like acid reflux.
Because it could cause you to burp,
it can also cause the sphincter
up here to not work well.
The sphincter is actually
what keeps the acid in the stomach.
That's where you want the acid to be
because when it starts coming up
and refluxing back into the esophagus,
it actually starts creating irritation.
That's when you get the
feeling of heartburn.
Make sure that you're
only drinking seltzer
if you're not suffering
with that type of heartburn,
and not too close to bedtime.
"Do you still consult a
doctor when you're sick,
or you consult yourself?"
Armand, great question.
I consult myself as well as the resources
that I use for my patients.
Like if a patient comes
in with a rare condition
that I'm not a hundred
percent sure how to treat,
I do consult those same sources,
whether they're websites, textbooks.
However, sometimes I do
go reach out for help.
Question, "So as long as I can remember,
my ankle has been cracking and
that's every time I more it."
I think you mean you move
it, but check this out.
I don't know if you hear it.
My ankles crack, in fact
when I walk up the steps,
my friends judge me, they're like,
"Dude, why do you sound
like you're 95 years old?"
I'm like, "Yeah, play
me in ball one on one
and we'll see how many years old I am!"
(upbeat music)
Banks open on Tuesdays folks.
"Why do I feel a little
heartbeat on the places I hurt,
like the tip of my fingers?"
You mean like the pulsating feeling
that you feel in your fingers
like when you hit them or jam them?
The pulsating feeling is a lot
of blood rushing to that area
to clot, to bring healing
factors, inflammatory cells.
It also gets warmer, it gets redder.
Those are all signs of inflammation.
It's how your body knows
something's going on.
Cuddle Muffinz, "Does your
heart stop when you sneeze?
Sometimes when I sneeze multiple times,
my chest starts to hurt."
Well first of all, your heart
stops beating all the time.
It beats relaxes beats relaxes.
So if you happen to sneeze
at the time of relaxes,
your heart's not beating.
I don't know if that counts.
The reason you're probably
experiencing chest pain
when you sneeze multiple times rapidly,
is because when you're trying to sneeze,
your body's also trying to
breathe and inhale your lung,
like expand your lungs.
And when you try and expand your chest,
those muscles are being pulled out.
But at the same time, you're sneezing.
So it's almost becomes
like a pulled muscle in between your ribs.
Imagine doing a curl,
and then all of a sudden
something comes and
stops you from doing it.
It's trains the muscle, and pulls it.
You know that wasn't the
greatest demonstration,
but I tried.
Hanna Belal, "My resting
bpm has got up to 160.
I'm still young, but I
don't think this is usual.
Is there a problem and
should I go to the doctor?"
Absolutely, you should
go as soon as you can.
The reason why I'm saying this,
is the resting heart rate should be 60
to a hundred beats per minute.
Anytime when you're at rest
and it's going above a hundred,
there needs to be a physiological reason
why that's happening.
Either a you're consuming a substance
that's raising your heart
rate, caffeine, drugs,
standing up and you're
going to exercise heavily.
That should, that can
raise your heart rate.
Stress, anxiety can raise it,
but to 160, that's a very high heart rate.
That signals to me that
something abnormal is going on
that desperately needs to be checked now.
Julian Vlogs, "Is having
interaction with your pet,
such as being licked, hugged, kissed,
hugging them or kissing them is harmful."
(dog licking)
Okay, that was an aggressive,
very slow motion kiss.
It's probably not great advice
for doctors to say that
your dog should lick you.
'Cause there is bacteria in his mouth,
probably not beneficial
in the long, long term
and there is a potential risk.
But like when I cuddle
with him and he kisses me,
oxytocin gets released and
that's like a cuddle hormone.
It makes you feel good,
it lowers your stress hormone levels.
So I love it, but medically
I can't recommend this type of licking.
(dog licking)
How long can he go?
I'm not in skinning.
Are you done?
John Paul Turingan,
how can I remove white
stretch marks on my shoulders?
Stretch marks are really difficult
if not impossible to remove.
Good way to think about them
it's almost like scar tissue.
It's literally from your
skin being overly stretched,
and scar tissue being laid down.
There are a few what
we call like aesthetic
or plastic surgeryic procedures
that can cut out these stretch marks.
But those come with obvious risks
and you need to weigh the
pros and cons for you.
The creams that are out there,
maybe they can help with the softness
or the suppleness of your
skin, but it's not gonna make
the stretch marks completely disappear.
Surgical procedures, possibly
some laser procedures
and then creams.
That's the order of efficacy,
going from best to worst.
"How come when I wash my
hands and then dry them?
They're still wet and
no need to say my name."
Did you dry them Well?
Like are you using a heavy moisturizer?
Are you sweating?
If you're sweating, are you nervous?
What are you nervous about?
Were you nervous that I was gonna try
and pronounce your name?
Your hand shouldn't be
wet after you dry them.
Kara Andrews, "Hi Dr.
Mike, love your content.
My question is whenever
you cough up any phlegm,
is it better to spit it out
or just swallow it or does it matter?"
It doesn't really matter.
Me personally, like if it's large enough,
I spit it out 'cause it's uncomfortable.
But if it's like a small
amount, feel free to swallow it.
Your body's capable of disinfecting it
because your gastric
contents have such a low pH
meaning it's such an acidic environment.
Kills any bacteria that
would be problematic.
"A naturopath told me once
that drinking while eating
discourages the enzymes to work.
What would you say to that please?"
I love drinking while eating, water.
It kind of fills up my stomach
and it prevents me from overeating,
and it helps food travel
down my esophagus.
And imagine we could just make
our digestive enzymes not work
because we had some water.
Oh my God, we would be the
least effective organism
on the planet.
Humans have survived thousands of years,
but if water goes into our system
the same time we have a big back,
we can't get its nutrients.
I went a little heavy on that.
Sorry naturopath Friends of mine.
Little Jugnoo, "Is it true
that keeping urine and bladder
for a longer time than
usual risks kidney health."
So let's start with explaining that
the average human bladder
holds 16 ounces of urine,
which is two cupful, two
cupfuls of urine literally.
So these are eight ounces each.
Letting your brain know
when it's time to go
is a really complex process.
So if you continuously
strain your bladder,
you could actually cause
yourself some serious problems.
You may retain urine after you urinate,
you don't have control
over your urination,
you could potentially have an increase
in urinary tract infections.
This isn't necessarily proven.
Logically make sense
that if you're keeping
that urine stagnant,
that bacteria has a higher
chance to multiply in that area.
But look, if you're just
holding it for a few minutes,
hour or two, it's not a big deal.
Know that your initial urge to go urinate
usually happens when your
bladder is about half full.
That's a good time for
you to go and urinate.
But if you need to wait an hour or two,
your body can handle it.
"Is Saturday truly for the boys."
No Saturday is for bear,
he's a boy you're right.
It is for the boys.
Nico, "Why does my anxiety caused anxiety?
Why am I more anxious in the evenings?'
Well, it's because anxiety's
a vicious, vicious cycle.
And in fact, one of the steps
that we try and teach our patients to do
is not to not have anxiety,
'cause that's a very difficult thing,
but it's to control the
thoughts you have about anxiety.
So if your thoughts are
driving your anxiety
to become worse and we
address those thoughts,
you could potentially
cut down your anxiety
about your anxiety.
That's what CBT is,
Cognitive Behavioral Therapy.
Check it out highly recommended,
not just for those who
suffer with anxiety,
but everyone on the planet.
I do CBT on myself quite often.
My question, "If someone wakes
up in the middle of surgery,
what do you do?"
I encourage them to go back
to sleep with some medicine.
Theofilos Myst question
"Does sudden pain, breaking your wrist,
increase the chances of passing out?"
Absolutely, passing out
from extreme anxiety,
stress, pain, even seeing your own blood.
All of this is a survival
mechanism to not overwhelm you.
You could absolutely
pass out from sun paints.
In fact, one of the hallmark
signs of breaking a bone
could be passing out
and getting really
nauseous at the same time.
Well, (chuckles)not at the same time,
because if you pass that
you're not nauseous,
but those are two signals.
Like I remember once, I've only
broken one bone in my body,
my left wrist, I was snowboarding
And I thought I was really cool
and I wasn't on the bunny slope
and I fell, and right
away I got so nauseous.
It wasn't even painful,
but that nausea, I knew,
I knew there was something wrong.
And when I came home, my dad told me,
yup, you broke your scaphoid,
just a bone in the wrist.
One of the most commonly
broken bones in the human body.
"I like to sing sometimes," me too.
Not very good at it, my question is,
"Is it possible for someone
who is partially disabled, I have POTS,
to go into med school.
I want to become a pathologist.
as it is something that has
played a huge part of my life,
anemia, and it has always
been interesting to me."
I think that you should
absolutely follow your dreams.
Just make sure that you're aware
of what you can do and can't do
so that you don't put yourself
in a dangerous position
or your patient in a dangerous position.
So for example, if you
know that you cannot stand
for an extended period of time,
don't do that just to please someone else,
explain what you're limited
in and find alternatives
or find programs who offer alternatives
in order for you to
participate in that education.
No person should be withheld in education
simply because they have a disability.
Mario Who, question for Dr. Mike,
"How does the lack of
affection affect your health?"
I see what you did there Maria.
Social connections laid into your life
play a huge role in the
quality of your life
and the length of your life.
These have to be meaningful
social connections,
they have to be positive ones.
Like is it beneficial to
your health to get married?
It depends if you have a happy marriage.
Happy marriage, yes, very
sad abusive marriage, no.
If you're getting positive
affection from your dog,
from your partner, absolutely
that's good for your health.
It lowers your stress hormone.
You get a release of oxytocin,
which is that cuddling hormone,
makes you feel good about yourself,
motivates you, lowers your blood pressure.
In fact, affection
encourages you to do things
like go outside for a walk,
experience new things.
And all of those things
are good for the human
mind and body, my body.
Do you know the truth about
cracking your knuckles,
or the truth about swallowing your gum?
Maybe what they told you isn't true.
Click on one of these and find out.
Oh yeah, and stay happy and healthy.
(gentle music)